hello and welcome everyone to yet
another tech enthusiastic video from
simply learn today we will learn to
handle exceptions in Java but before we
begin please be kind enough to get
subscribed to our YouTube channel and
hit the bell icon so that you can stay
updated about the trending technologies
in the current industry also if you're
looking for an online training and
certification program on the latest
technologies like data science machine
learning and artificial intelligence or
to master the cutting-edge programming
languages like Java Python c-sharp etc
then please visit the simply learn
official website to enroll master and
get certified now without much ado let's
dive into our session we will start off
with the agenda first we will learn the
basic definition of an error and an
exception after that we will learn the
basic differences between an error and
an exception then we get into the Iraqi
of exceptions faced in Java followed by
that we will learn the different types
of exceptions that we face ensure
after that we will learn how to handle
exceptions in Java
using the five important keywords using
exception handling in Java programming
language followed by that we will try to
solve some of the most frequently faced
exceptions in Java finally we will go
through the best practices that will
help us using exceptions while coding in
real time I hope I made myself clear
with the agenda now let us begin with
our first topic that is what is an
exception
so an exception is defined as an event
that arises due to an unexpected input
or logical failure in the program this
may not be considered nearly as an error
but it surely does impact the normal
functioning of the program segment now
these types of exceptions are resolved
by the most efficient mechanism called
exception handling exception handling is
not any rocket science but a simple
mechanism that drives the compiler to
the next statement by making the
compiler understand that the input
obtained or the malfunction that arise
is just an unexpected or an unnecessary
event which can be ignored by sending
the user with a relevant message about
the exception arrows for a better
understanding let us go through a small
example
so as you can see on a screen we have
type in a program so according to this
program we are going to access a file
called data dot txt from the C Drive so
this particular data dot txt is not
really existing in the C Drive so when
we run this program we will face an
exception that says file is not fun so
let's try to run this program and see
so as expected so when we run this
program we get that this particular file
what you're looking for which is data
dot txt is not fun or in other words it
is not present in the specified location
so this is how the exceptions work in
Java now followed by this we will move
ahead into our next topic where we will
understand the meaning of an error so
what exactly is an error so here we are
trying to learn about the error just to
eliminate the ambiguity between an
exception and an error also further we
will discuss the major differences
between them but now let us go through
the term errors first unlike an
exception and error poses a serious
potential threat to the program or
sometimes it is even capable enough to
collapse an entire software so basically
an error is occurred due to syntax error
or some logical error while coding so we
have a sound understanding of an
exception and an error now let us move
further and learn the differences
between the boat
Hado versus exception so some of the
major differences between an error and
an exception are and error is classified
under unchecked by whereas on the other
hand an exception is classified under
both checked and unchecked the next
difference is if a program encounters an
error then it turns out to be completely
irrecoverable until the error is
resolved
whereas in the case of an exception if
the program encounters an exception then
the program is easily recoverable
followed by that the third difference is
an error belongs to the package called
Java dot Lang dot error on the other
hand an exception belongs to the class
Java dot Lang dot exception the fourth
difference says that an error can be
encountered only during the program's
runtime whereas on the other hand an
exception can be expected both during
the runtime as well as the compile time
finally we were mentioned an example for
both an error and an exception making
consider the input and output error as
an example for error and on the other
hand we can consider divide by zero
exception as an example for exception
so what the defense is discussed we will
now move it and have a look at the
exception hierarchy in Java
the hierarchy of errors and exceptions
is really simple
there is one root class called the
trouble now the throwable class is
basically inherited from object which
comes from the superior root called Java
dot lang
now the throwable class is inherited by
two child classes which are none other
than the error and an exception further
an error is inherited by different types
of errors for example JVM or java
virtual machine error memory error and
also in some cases some of the errors
are caused by the incompatibility of the
IDE or the framework which are you are
using next up is the exception now the
exception is inherited by a few more
exceptions which are mentioned as below
the exceptions can be input/output
exception sequel exception class notes
found exception runtime exception and
many more further the runtime exception
is inherited by some more which are the
automatic exception number format
exception etc now that we have a good
understanding of the exception hierarchy
let us move ahead and check the
differences between shared and unchecked
exceptions
so the first one which is the checked
exceptions these are really simple
exceptions and can be defined as follows
an exception that pops up during the
compile time is called as the chip
exception it is not serious and is
completely ignore Abell followed by the
checked exceptions we have the unchecked
exceptions on the other hand the
unchecked exceptions are defined as an
exception that pops up during the run
time is called as the an checked
exception it is considered a serious and
is caused by logical errors so to
understand check exceptions in a much
better way we shall go through an
example so this particular example is
based on checked exceptions so basically
we have a text document called data dot
txt in the location documents username
users see try
so this particular data file has five
ones so we are going to access the
starting three lines of this particular
file and basically when we try to run
this program we will face some of the
major exceptions which are unhandled
exception type input and again the same
exception and here file not found
exception so these exceptions are errors
so to understand
shake the exceptions in a much better
way we shall go through an example so
this particular code segment here is
trying to read a document from C Drive
which is data dot txt so this particular
data dot PhD has five lines of text so
what we are going to do here is try to
type in a for loop and try to read the
first three lines of this particular
document
so basically when we run this program
we will face some of the exceptions
called file not found exception
input/output exception and another
input-output exception
so we can resolve this particular
program with small modifications to the
program and then if you run this program
then we can find our lines so the lines
in the data dot txt file hello welcome
present later on we are an e-learning
company our certification is recognized
by major MNCs end-all and upscale so
this particular example was for check
exceptions
now we will also go through an example
for unchecked exceptions to learn it in
a much better way
so this particular example is based on
unchecked exceptions this particular
program is really simple we have an
integer type array and inside that we
have ten elements which are one two
three four five six seven eight nine and
ten
so what we are going to do is we are
going to access the eleventh element of
the adding which is not really present
so this should throw an exception
so array index out of bounds exception
is one of the example for unchecked
exceptions
so with this we will move it into our
next topic
now we know what exactly are checked and
unchecked exceptions moving further we
will slowly dive into the process of
exception handling in the process of
exception handling we have five major
keywords
so we will learn each one of them as
follows so the first one is try keyword
the try keyword is used to specify the
exception lock in a program when you
specifically type the exception that you
might expect to face in your program
then you describe it using the keyword
try followed by that the solution for
that exception will be defined in the
catch so the catch block is used to
specify the solution finally the finally
is a keyword which has the executable
code which is completely mandatory for a
program to execute followed by finally
we have a throw keyword the throw
keyword basically throws the exception
when it is found during the run time
followed by that we have the throws the
throws keyword is used to declare the
exception so basically this is where you
declare the kind of exception you are
going to expect a new program sometimes
you might try to type in your user
defined exception or sometimes you might
type in the exception that is default in
its range or in other words it might be
system defined
now that we have a good understanding of
the implementation of the exception
handling in Java let us move further and
so some of the most frequently faced
exceptions in Java
so with this we enter into our seventh
topic which is common exceptions faced
in Shaba
so the first one is the array index out
of pound
so if you try to store a value in an
array or try to access an element in an
array which has an address exceeding the
add is maximum location value then this
particular exception is thrown so to
understand this particular exception let
us go through a practical example
so as you can see on our screen we have
an array of integer datatype so we are
going to store the values 10 20 30 40
and 50 in five different locations of
the array which is 0 1 2 3 & 4 now we
are going to provide the address of the
required element so during that process
we are going to specify one location
which is more than the maximum location
of the array so here the maximum
location of the array is 4 and if we try
to provide the location 5 then this
program should throw us an exception so
let's try to run this program and see
so as you can see we have our array here
now the program is requesting us to
provide the address of the element
required so what if we provide five
so now it should throw an exception so
this exception is the array index out of
bounds exception now let us try to run
this program again and specify the
proper address so for this time let's
provide for and see if we get the output
so as you can see at the address
location we have the element 50 as we
have defined
now our program is running perfectly all
right now let's move it into the next
type of exception which is known
nullpointerexception
if you try to perform an operation on a
null value this particular exception is
thrown so might be little ambiguous to
understand this particular exception in
a perfect way let us go through a
practical exam
so here on your screen you can see that
we have a program and inside the program
we have a strain for STR which stores a
text called Cynthia followed by that we
have another strength type which stores
unknown value which is ABC as a TC ABC
is equals to none now here we are going
to access the value of BBC so here the
string ABC has a null value and we are
trying to access it so this particular
code segment should throw an exception
called null pointer exception now let's
try to execute this code
as you can see it has thrown an
exception called the
nullpointerexception so whenever in Java
if you try to access the null values
then the null pointer exception is
strong
followed by this we have the next type
of the common exception which is the
number format if you try to store a
value with wrong formatting then this
particular exception is thrown now to
understand this in a much better way let
us try to execute a sample program so
here on the screen we have a sample
program
where we had found to cast a string into
integer so this kind of operation should
throw an exception
so as you can see the program has been
successfully compiled and we have our
exception here which says number format
exception followed by this we have
another most commonly faced exception
which is the automatic expression if you
try to divide a number by zero this
particular exception is thrown now let
us go through a practical exam
now you can see we have a sample program
on our screen where we have two
particular numbers and one is equals to
0 and n 2 is equals to 100 so here what
we are trying to do this
we are going to divide the number
hundred passenger which is practically
not possible so when we try to execute
this particular program then we should
be getting an exception that says you
cannot divide a number by C
so there you have you personalized
message which says the divider cannot be
0 try a different number so this is how
the automatic exceptions work
so with this we have come to our last
topic which is the best practices to be
followed while working with exceptions
in Java
so the first one is use exceptions
insulated so exceptions have proven that
they can be costly if used recklessly or
unnecessary so it's better if we use
boolean values to indicate successful
implementation of smaller operations for
example if you specify a particular
operation and it successfully gets
executed then you can just notify the
user by specifying a boolean value which
can be 1 or in the case of failure you
can just specify the number 0
next after that we have the customized
exceptions it is a very good practice of
customizing your exceptions in the
design point rather than cloning them on
the goal so in other words we can
consider this as if you're planning to
design a software then in that
particular stage with cinge
you must also evaluate the kind of
exceptions you might chase on the
process of design so tomorrow if you
completely design a software and
suddenly an exception is pop in your
head then designing or including that
part of the exception in your finished
software might be digital so it's better
you start planning your exceptions
followed by that we have exception
logging keep track of the exceptions and
this process comes handy as the user
understands why exactly a particular
exception has fought
followed by that we have early through
an urgency the next session should be
shown as early as possible and should be
resolved in the same piece
and then we have the close in resources
since exceptions filed the complete
program we must make sure that the
system resources are checked so as to
save the resources
so with this we have come to an end of
this session I hope this was resourceful
if we have any queries regarding this
session then please feel free to drop
them down in the comment section below
also don't forget to get subscribe to
the simply learn youtube channel and hit
a liking to stay connected to us and get
important updates based on the current
IT this is Robbie signing off thank you
until next time
hi there if you liked this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here